let's went down on the auto girl we are
at an alto grill it is a highway rest up
over the alto strata in this case it's
not you know 8 1 an outdoor grill is a
fantastic Italian creation which has
some coffee in all of Italy the way it
works a lot of people don't understand
this that they haven't visited before is
the page first aim hey first to be paid
for I don't pay to like taste no taste
no bang you see here you don't taste
until you pay
I taste and then I pay
what if I know like we define it saves
no life then the next time you taste
something else you pay first
no delays in fact to you yes pay and
they may or may not taste
that's your tour you will not okay
[Music]
today I got the boot Felina you see
sometimes if Ronaldo will have different
sandwich selections they said the same
ones over and over again but here in the
South they may be to some southern
products
we're kind of in central Italy right now
southern Tuscany so I just done with a
group Elina
it's got mozzarella cheese on the roof
alone fact and
that's my favorite at this particular
location so that is the summary of the
Italian Alto Grill you can consider
yourself an expert
you